during the new movie at the moment ron
howard's new movie in the heartless sea
so we're we're pretty early starts late
finishes and yes pretty tiring so I'm
quite tired at the moment what's it like
working with Ron Howard as a director
I've always always wanted to work with
Ron Howard I'm a massive fan of his
movies you know he's already got you
know two Oscars I'm sure he's going to
add to that collection it's such a short
space of time so nice fantastic he's a
legend and it's nice to be working with
him ill of course Ted doubling again for
Chris Hemsworth what was it like to
working with him again yeah Chris is
Chris amazing love working with Chris
yeah we I did a movie Jupiter ascending
with Channing Tatum and Mila Kunis early
part of this year so I wasn't working
with Chris Chris was doing something
else but we're back together now working
in the heart the series of saying and
looking forward to starting Avengers
next year as well wow you are so busy
honestly you look at your filmography
it's just packed it really is I think
it's been great been very very lucky so
far may it continue
now you mentioned Jupiter ascending
there as well of course you were dipping
for Channing Tatum for that one you that
the first time you work with him and
what was he like
Channing absolutely lovely guy really
nice guy super athletic pretty much
doesn't everything himself anyway you
know it's great really nice to work with
Chomsky's big fans that fans are there
that those you know they're obviously
done the matrix and the matrix one being
so successful so now it's great yeah
it's good job how does it compare when
you're on all these different jobs
because obviously they're quite
different films but be you as a stunt
guy I mean how does it compare it really
depends on what the movie is I mean if
it's if you know super you're a movie
you know it's pretty much it says what
it is on the tin you know it's a lot of
action lots of fights lots of why I work
so there's a massive period of
rehearsals that we have to you know
undergo and it could be like an eight
week or nine week rehearsal period
before we start shooting so it just
depends on what the movie is and how
action orientated it is but generally
will will be one of the the crews that
start the movie and finish it and be on
it you know the longest
sometimes we can be on a film for maybe
nine months there's on The Dark Knight
Rises for nine months
it's a long long period so we have a lot
of rehearsal time before to try and
eliminate
as much danger as possible so yeah you
mentioned Dark Knight Rises a course
with Christine Bell again you were
stunned opening for him were you on that
one yeah I was Christian bow again and
another actor was an absolute pleasure
to work with a big fan of his and so
glad he got the Oscar for the fighter
but yeah that was that was certainly an
amazing experience to work with Chris
Nolan again as I didn't inception within
you know the likes of you know Morgan
Freeman Michael Caine I work with Joseph
again from inception Christian and
Hathaway the list goes on it was just
amazing experience great locations in
the UK in the US and yeah that's
definitely a highlight of my career so
far it's really a Hollywood for you
isn't it who you're working with yeah I
mean again I've been so lucky to work
with with the guys I've worked with and
they're all so humble and down-to-earth
and you know they're all super athletic
as well which kind of makes our job
easier I think I've been very lucky in
that respect that the guys can all move
super well and you know it just makes
again like I said my job much easier
obviously people you work with more than
once they like Chris how'd it how does
that affect how you work than when
you've all you work with before I think
you build over a period of time like a
rapport and a relationship with them and
you know hopefully you can gain a bit of
trust from them and vice-versa and you
know it's it's nice to have someone that
you work with often you know how that
how they are and what they want and you
know that's nice for them as well to
have that you know they know they've got
someone that they can trust them rely on
and for stunts it's you know it can be
quite dangerous so to have that on your
side as well it works in both favors you
mentioned about the guys that you've
worked with being quite athletic and
physical how does that help you as a guy
you're working with them again for
fights and stunts it makes it easier
because they can do you know a lot
themselves and as far as teaching them
certain things they pick it up so easy
but I think more importantly is the the
training in the preparation than before
that you know to get in the shape that
you have to get in to stunt-double that
certain person for example with Chris on
Thor I've never had to train so hard in
normal life it was it was six days a
week you know three hours a day two
sessions two sessions that they
and the diet was super intense you know
it's to try and put on a lot of bulk
because Chris is naturally a big guy
anyway and stay lean as well so that's
what I found the most difficult thing to
do and today is is the most difficult
I've had to be in shape or for a movie
now you mentioned of course Thor there
what's it like wielding that famous
hammer yeah it was great I mean the
costumes great Chris always looks
fantastic in it as well and with the
hammer so yeah it was great we had
different weights for different things
for it so I mean it would you know
certain shots close-ups would be you
know the full the full hammer like super
heavy hammer and then certain stunt
scenes it'd be a lighter weight so you
can move it around you know a bit easier
but no it was going I mean fantastic
opportunity to do that job so yeah and
you were working with them Game of
Thrones director Alan Taylor for that
one weren't you what was he like what
did he bring to Thor the dark world do
you think yeah great I mean it's first
time I've worked with him and you know
obviously everyone knows about what he's
done and what he's achieved so I think
his forte is the way he shoots things
they've always been you know come across
as being very beautiful and I don't
think it's gonna be any different for
the Dark Knight Rises sorry for Thor the
dark world is going to be exactly the
same I mean what he shoots is fantastic
of course the fans are super excited
about another Marvel movie another Thor
movie and what can fans look forward to
anything I think he wants to be
disappointing to be fantastic
comedy side of it's great there's lots
of action as always you know this fight
you know it's huge the CG he's gonna be
fantastic so I think it's definitely
gonna be up there with you know
the Avengers and Iron Man 3 can't wait
now of course as well as I'm Tom
Hiddleston and of course Chris Hemsworth
and yourself on board again we've got
also coming in new Christopher Eccleston
has a haven't we I mean you're working
with him as well weren't you as well as
Tom Hiddleston what are those guys like
to work with great they're all super
professional fantastic and their jobs
and Christopher Eccleston was again you
know he's Doctor Who and stuff like that
and to work with him was great I was
always a big fan of his and he plays a
fantastic Malekith so yeah great
something Austin's the same I think some
people since one of the best acts we've
got in the UK right now
I think this query is just going to keep
rising and rising and rising I mean
actually even fans of Tom have been
petitioning for lucky to have his own
movie what do you think about I mean
it's exactly if the fans are there then
why not I mean he's if he's obviously
got a huge fan base I think he's
fantastic and what he does as well he's
great so there's no reason why not and
I'm sure he will be up for it
how much further the teaming up with
Loki for the latest movie yeah great I
mean the relationship that the the
Brothers of God is is fantastic and then
the next installment again will show
that in more depth I think I think Loki
playing that character I think tom is
perfect for I don't think anyone else
could play it like he does and vice
versa same store I mean with Chris is
just a perfect thought the way they play
is they've got it down to a tee what's
the atmosphere like on sex I get the
sense because obviously these guys that
will work together before on various
movies now it's quite kind of light they
get on very well definitely I mean what
I've experienced working with them guys
and them being together as they've like
said they've worked together before so
it just makes it so much easier they've
got great relationships and I think they
all bounce off of each other you know
Natalie Portman's the same she's
fantastic at what she does and I think
on set what's nice to see is the whole
crew have such respect for those guys
for what they're doing and what they've
transformed this franchise into you
mentioned earlier we're talking about
Avengers 2 and getting going on that
when when do you think you'll be working
on that
early next year I'll be starting on
Avengers 2 hopefully if all goes to plan
you never know what can happen but yeah
hopefully next year I'm looking forward
to that one I thought the first one was
absolutely fantastic
I was actually filming in Turkey on
Skyfall we the team went to go and watch
it and it was just like wow I thought is
incredible to get them all together and
and you know what they have individually
to come together as a team was it was
fantastic to watch it just the comedy
side of it just made that extra you know
made it extra bit special and it was
fantastic what do you think it just
Whedon it's brilliant I think he's a
fantastic director as you guys know
already he helped out with he helped
Ellen Taylor on for the second
installment he definitely knows what
he's doing that's for sure and I think
the next one's going to be just as good
if not about a bit disappointed but also
still obviously massively looking
forward to that with hearing that maybe
Loki's not going to be in Avengers 2
because you've got other baddies who are
gonna be in there and stared you'd be
sad to lose Loki I don't know anything
about that side of it I've not heard you
know be a bish you know be I'm not sure
if they will be losing locally such a
massive part to the franchise but I mean
I don't actually know anything about
that side of it now you mentioned um
Skyfall as well which is another
fantastic movie that you worked on and
we've got another bond maybe coming up
Sam Mendes onboard again are you gonna
be hoping to be on bond 24 and if so
what would you like to see in there yeah
I mean I'd love to be in a British boy
as well it's always something that you
want to do and my first ever job
actually and was quantum of solace this
is the second installment of Daniels
collection that he's building so I mean
I'd love to yeah be fantastic but could
it just were it just depends on
schedules and you know what I'm doing at
the time and filming wise and you know
it you know might not be asked to do it
you know you just never know and who the
stunt coordinators going to be but if I
have an opportunity to do it would be
great I'd love to hear Daniel said
recently that he'd like to see some more
dry humor that we've seen in bonds in
the past but back into future bonds what
do you think about that yeah I mean it's
great I mean there's such a huge fan
base you know spanned over 50 years
I think Daniel for me is the best bond
that we've had
and I think he can deliver that side of
it as well and you know hopefully it's I
think Skyfall was such a success and the
performance from Javier Bardem and you
know Casino Royale being such a success
his first movie you know bond fans must
be you know so pleased with what's
happened so far we've heard also that
Noemi Harris is going to be getting out
from behind the desk as Moneypenny and
having a bit more of a sidekick role
possibly in the next Bond movie I mean
if she just get out from behind that
desk more what what would you think of
that was that something you'd look
forward to yeah I mean it'd be great I
mean she was fantastic
you know in Skyfall so that'd be
fantastic we no reason why she shouldn't
I think the more that they add to it it
just you know it gets better and better
there so I'm interesting I'm very
interested to see who the next villain
is gonna be I think to follow
Javier's performance will be something
that's quite a feat to achieve because I
think he's fantastic he's such a great
actor and I think you've laid that part
so well so yeah be interesting to see
you the next villains gonna be you
always got to have a good villain in
Bond to really make an Avenue and Javier
Bardem it's brilliant yeah definitely I
think you have to I think that's what
makes the bomb movies I mean Daniel
himself is always fantastic but you know
to make that character even better for
Daniel they need that villain that's you
know makes that difference and Xavier
definitely stepped up to the plate and
then Mendes is you know he's already got
you know look at his you know caliber of
what he's already done and for him to
take on this second one you know proves
how good he is away that he could have
just left it there and gone okay the
success of Skye form we leave it there
but for him to take it on again is you
know it should be huge cannot wait
another movie to look forward to and
Maleficent as well as another one that
you've been working on and tell us a
little bit about what you have to do on
that I worked on my levels to learn
anything maybe like four or five weeks
on it and the stunt coordinator unis I
thought I'm actually working with her
now she's the stunt coordinator for in
the heart of the scene which which I'm
film with Ron Howard Chris Hemsworth
but I think that's gonna be great I mean
Angie is you know she's got such a huge
following and she's you know she's again
fantastic at what she does so I'm
looking forward to seeing that come and
be very difference what we will expect
as somebody who's part of the business I
know works on assets do you still have
which were sent some kind of Fernan
entertainment and enthusiasm and
excitement do you still have when you
kind of see these big movies on the big
screen and you've been part of it huge
amounts I mean you know it's already a
big film fan anyway even if I wasn't
working in them so I mean it's great to
be part of you know both sides of it
working on them and being a huge fan I
think the first time that you watch the
film that you may have worked on is
quite difficult to take the movie and as
the movie on its own because you're
always thinking about what you guys did
or will be in there so it's very
different than you have to watch it a
couple of times to actually appreciate
it and take the whole whole movie in so
yeah I think watching a movie from the
outside not working on it is much easier
to watch than the films you've actually
worked on but we actually went to the
cinema last night to watch prisoners
didn't work on that movie but to go and
watch it and not be working on it so
much easier to take it in to questions I
suppose that come to mind after you said
that one is how kind of self-critical
are you when you're watching something
and you watching and think it'll work
that's done I did it like this or
someone else did it like that maybe not
next time or I think of a different way
of doing it and also if you watch a film
like prisoners last night are you
looking at it as a stuntman and thinking
oh that was interesting or wonder how
they did that no it's funny I mean I'm
always critical of what I do and I'm
sure every you know it's goes the same
for the actors you know we was gonna be
critical were ever happy with what we
see but watching a movie that I'm not
involved in it has stunts you know
you're kind of watching the film for
what it is and then you see the stunts
you know okay well that was great or
that was a bit dodgy it just depends I
think you definitely see it in a
different light but I'm always critical
about my own performance and what can we
look forward to coming it from you I
know you're working on part of the scene
at the moment but after that heartlessly
at a moment that finishes late December
and then hopefully fingers crossed if it
works out and you know I get the
opportunity which I'm hoping to Avengers
2 which is what I'm really looking
forward to being such a big fan of the
Marvel franchise and how successful you
know that the first Avengers was I'm
hoping that
I hope not get to work on that we do is
there particular people that you'd
actually say oh my god I'd love to see
them back please let them come back for
revenge us too
I think they all will be back I mean I
you know no one's certain but you'd hope
they were all gonna be back I'm sure
they ain't going to introduce new
characters as well as they always do but
I mean there's so many that are in the
movie I think you know and there's such
strong characters you know I think it's
going to be it's going to be great it's
been lovely to speak to Bobby thanks so
much for your time so much
you